Monica Childs worked her way up on the police force in Detroit, from patrol to the vice squad to homicide. She was part of an elite team of investigators. But why'd she become a police officer?
莫妮卡·柴尔德斯在底特律警局通过努力从基层升起，从巡警到扫黄组再到凶杀组。她是精英调查小组的一员。但她为什么会成为一名警察呢？
I became the police because I didn't like the police. During the time I grew up, the police officers I always saw in my community were always male and white, over six feet tall. It was rare that a police officer talked to you like you were a human being. Everything was always confrontational. And I always saw police officers as the biggest gang in town. It's just a gang, a band of hoodlums with badges.
我成为警察是因为我不喜欢警察。在我成长的过程中，我社区里的警察总是白人男性，身高超过六英尺。他们很少像对待人类一样与你交谈。一切总是充满对抗。我一直认为警察是城里最大的帮派。他们只是一个帮派，一群带着徽章的流氓。
And I always wondered, did they go around recruiting them like this or putting ads in the paper that you must have a bad attitude and misuse and abuse the citizens? Where did these people come from? So I thought, well, OK, all police officers aren't bad. There's got to be some good ones somewhere.
我总是纳闷，他们是这样招募人的吗？还是在报纸上登广告说你必须态度恶劣、滥用职权并虐待市民？这些人是从哪来的？所以我心想，好吧，并非所有警察都是坏的。总得有些好警察吧。
And so she joined the force to try to change the system from inside. And on the job, she saw how police get to be the way they are, how police band together. When they make mistakes, they never admit it, she says. They cover up each other's mistakes, almost from the time they come onto the force.
于是她加入了警队，试图从内部改变体制。在工作中，她看到了警察是如何变成那样的，看到了他们是如何抱团的。她说，当他们犯错时，他们从不承认。他们几乎从进入警队的那一刻起就开始相互包庇错误。
These people would come on with their own ideas and opinions. And then, they would adapt these other people's attitudes. Everybody became one, like a marriage, because police organizations reward people for what? They reward everybody for being the same. If you're different, you're ostracized or you have problems.
这些人带着自己的想法和见解进入警队。然后，他们会采纳别人的态度。每个人都变得一样，就像婚姻一样，因为警察组织奖励什么人？他们奖励那些随大流的人。如果你与众不同，你就会被排挤或遇到麻烦。
Banding together, there's nothing wrong with banding together. There's absolutely nothing wrong with that. That's not the problem. The problem is when you band together, and you all act in concert to lie, perpetuate a scenario that didn't happen. That's where the problem lies.
团结起来并没有什么错。这绝对没有任何问题。问题不在于此。问题在于当你抱团时，你们共同撒谎，编造并未发生的事实。问题就在这里。
And you got that one little meek person that doesn't want to go along, but goes along because, "We're all police, and we got to stick together. It's us against them." Where else do you hear that? Gangs-- us against them. And that "them" that you're referring to, "us against them," I like those people out there. I like the public at large.
而你身边那个温顺、不想同流合污的人，却因为“我们都是警察，我们必须团结一致。是我们对抗他们”的想法而随大流。你在别处听过这种话吗？帮派——是我们对抗他们。而你所说的那个“他们”，我其实挺喜欢那些人。我喜欢广大公众。
So whenever Monica Childs started on a new job at the force, she would let everybody know how she felt about things.
所以每当莫妮卡·柴尔德斯开始一份新工作时，她都会让大家知道她对事情的看法。
And it was always interesting because I'd tell them, I say, "You know, I don't lie and cover up for anybody. Whatever you do, if it's wrong, and I'm asked about it, I will tell. I'm not covering for you. I'm not going to lie for you. I won't even say I didn't see it or didn't hear. But I don't want you to lie for me. And I don't want you to cover up for me, either."
这总是很有趣，因为我会告诉他们：“你知道，我不会为任何人撒谎和掩盖。无论你做了什么，如果是错的，如果被问到，我会说出来。我不会为你掩盖。我不会为你撒谎。我甚至不会说我没看见或没听见。但我也不希望你为我撒谎，也不希望你为我掩盖。”
And that approach worked for Monica Childs for years, until finally, in 1996, it stopped working. And her life as a cop became very difficult. Today on our program, Can You Fight City Hall If You Are City Hall? We bring you two stories, each about somebody trying to change the system from within, trying to be principled while working in government.
这种方法在莫妮卡·柴尔德斯身上奏效了多年，直到1996年终于失效了。她作为警察的生活变得非常艰难。今天在我们的节目中，主题是“如果你就是市政府，你还能对抗市政府吗？”我们将带来两个故事，每个故事都关于试图从内部改变体制的人，试图在政府工作时坚守原则。
This is, of course, the July 4 holiday weekend. And it's a holiday about a moment of idealism that created the American government. Our show today is about what happens to people trying to sustain that kind of idealism today. In each story, public-minded public servants end up fighting their colleagues. It takes a toll on their lives. They get harassed. They lose their jobs.
这当然是7月4日的假期周末。这是一个关于创造美国政府的理想主义时刻的节日。我们今天的节目是关于那些试图在今天维持这种理想主义的人会经历什么。在每个故事中，有公共精神的公务员最终与同事发生冲突。这给他们的生活带来了代价。他们受到骚扰，失去工作。
Act One, Take That, Copper, in which an honest cop tries to do the right thing, and a suspected murderer walks free as a result. Act Two, Man Versus Money, a small-town mayor tries to keep a developer from building in his town. And it results in the kind of snowballing fiasco by the end of which, the town literally does not exist anymore. Alix Spiegel tells that story.
第一幕，“教训一下警察”，讲述了一名诚实的警察试图做正确的事，结果一名嫌疑谋杀犯被释放了。第二幕，“人与钱的较量”，一个小镇市长试图阻止开发商在镇上大兴土木。这导致了一场雪崩式的惨败，最终那个小镇甚至都不复存在了。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔讲述了这个故事。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One: Take That, Copper. So Monica Child's troubles began on August 20, 1996. An 11-year-old boy was murdered the night before. And when she got to work, her commanding officer had a suspect in the crime sitting there in the office.
第一幕：教训一下警察。莫妮卡·柴尔德斯的麻烦始于1996年8月20日。前一天晚上，一名11岁的男孩被谋杀。当她上班时，她的指挥官办公室里坐着一名犯罪嫌疑人。
She orders me to take his statement. I said, "Take his statement?" I say, "No."
她命令我为他做笔录。我说：“做笔录？不。”
I try to get other people on the squad to do it. Nobody else would do it. Because what she did was illegal, and she was trying to involve me in an illegal action.
我试图让小组里的其他人去做。没人愿意做。因为她所做的是违法的，她试图让我参与违法行为。
It was illegal because her superior had made an improper promise to the suspect. She told him that if he confessed, he would be sent home, which of course was untrue. If he confessed, he would be thrown in jail and put on trial. Monica Childs finally agreed to take his statement and the statement of another witness. But as their day in court approached, her boss kept coming into her office, asking what she was going to say in the hearing.
之所以违法，是因为她的上级对嫌疑人做出了不当承诺。她告诉他，如果他认罪，就会被送回家，这当然是谎言。如果他认罪，他会被投入监狱并接受审判。莫妮卡·柴尔德斯最终同意为他和另一名证人做笔录。但随着庭审日期的临近，她的老板不断走进她的办公室，询问她在听证会上会说什么。
She came in this office. I was sitting there. She'd come in, and she says, "I need to know what you're going to say at the [? Walken ?] hearing." I said, "I'm going to tell the truth."
她走进这间办公室。我坐在那里。她走进来，说：“我需要知道你在[沃肯]听证会上会说什么。”我说：“我会说实话。”
"I need to know exactly what you're going to say." I said, "Well, the truth of what I'm going to say, I went in saying I told you to straighten this mess up. I'm not lying for you. I told you I wasn't going to lie for you. I'm going to tell the truth."
“我需要准确地知道你会说什么。”我说：“好吧，实话实说，我进去后会说我告诉过你要把这烂摊子理清楚。我不会为你撒谎。我告诉过你我不会为你撒谎。我会说实话。”
Finally, Monica Childs called the prosecuting attorney and told him what was going on, and the suspect's statement was thrown out. He not only went free, he sued the police department over the way they treated him and won a settlement of $15,000. This man, Reginald Vines, says that he is innocent of all charges.
最终，莫妮卡·柴尔德斯联系了检察官并告诉了他发生的事情，嫌疑人的供词被驳回了。他不仅被释放，还因警方对待他的方式起诉了警察局，并赢得了1.5万美元的赔偿。这名男子雷金纳德·维恩斯声称自己是无辜的。
Meanwhile, Monica Childs's boss had her transferred to a job where she had no specific duties at all. Friends on the force stopped speaking to her, people she'd known for years. Police work is the kind of job where you work closely with other people, spending hours together tracking down leads, going over the case, just in each other's company. Now this was gone.
与此同时，莫妮卡·柴尔德斯的老板将她调到了一个没有任何具体职责的岗位。警队的同事们不再跟她说话，即使是那些她认识多年的人。警察工作需要与人密切合作，花数小时一起追踪线索、审视案件，总是在彼此陪伴中工作。现在这一切都没了。
They were afraid to talk to me. They'd say, "Monica, wait   'til we get outside. I'll talk to you outside because I don't want to get in the middle of this. I don't wan to be seen talking to you." I said, "Oh. OK. All right."
他们不敢跟我说话。他们会说：“莫妮卡，等我们出去再说。我会在外面跟你说话，因为我不想卷入这件事。我不想被人看到跟你说话。”我说：“哦。好的。没问题。”
So I wasn't angry with them. I wish I could've gotten the National Enquirer to come, because I've never seen people walk without a spine. And that definitely would've been an Enquirer or a Globe story.
所以我并不生他们的气。我真希望我能找《国家询问报》来，因为我从没见过这么没骨气的人。那绝对会是个《询问报》或《全球报》的故事。
Retaliation against whistleblowers is so common that a Washington, DC group that tries to help government employees in this situation, the Government Accountability Project, put out a handbook warning potential whistleblowers that typically they can expect any and all of the following-- character attacks, threats, isolation, public humiliation, prosecution on trumped-up charges, the elimination of their jobs, blacklisting, even physical assaults. Childs sued the police department. The local press picked up the story. And in the midst of all this, she got a phone call.
对举报人的报复太常见了，以至于华盛顿特区一个试图帮助处于这种困境中的政府雇员的组织“政府问责项目”，发布了一本手册，警告潜在的举报人，他们通常会遭遇以下任何或所有情况——人格攻击、威胁、孤立、公开羞辱、捏造罪名起诉、解雇、列入黑名单，甚至身体攻击。柴尔德斯起诉了警察局。当地媒体报道了这件事。就在这一切之中，她接到了一个电话。
"Hey, Miss Childs, how are you doing?" I said, "Who is this?" "Oh, this is Eric. You don't remember me?" "No."
“嘿，柴尔德斯女士，你好吗？”我说：“你是谁？”“哦，我是埃里克。你不记得我了？”“不。”
The guy turned out to be a murderer who Monica Childs had caught.
这个人竟然是莫妮卡·柴尔德斯抓捕的一名杀人犯。
I go "OK." I said, "Well, where are you?" "I'm in prison. Remember, I got life." I said, "Oh. OK. What you want?"
我说：“好吧。你在哪？”“我在监狱里。记得吗，我被判了终身监禁。”我说：“哦。好的。你想干什么？”
He says, "We've been reading about all this trouble and all these problems that this police department trying to cause you. Me and some friends up here in prison that know you, you were their detective, too." I said, "I was their detective? I thought you were entitled to have your own lawyer. I didn't know you had your own detective."
他说：“我们一直在读关于警察局试图给你制造的所有麻烦和问题。我和这里的几个朋友都认识你，你也是他们的警探。”我说：“我是他们的警探？我以为你有权拥有自己的律师。我不知道你还有自己的警探。”
"Oh, yeah, yeah. It's about 12 or 13 of us. We was sitting around. And if you need us to come and be character witnesses for you, you let us out, and we'll come down there because you was cool with us. When we went to trial, you didn't lie on us. You didn't add nothing to it. Most of us doing life, we got big time. But we was wrong. But I just appreciated the way you get me. And you didn't lie."
“哦，是的，是的。我们有12或13个人。我们坐在一起聊。如果你需要我们来为你做性格证人，你把我们放出去，我们会去那里的，因为你对我们很公平。当我们受审时，你没有诬陷我们。你没有编造任何东西。我们大多数人被判了终身监禁，我们罪有应得。但我们错了。我很感激你对待我的方式。你没有撒谎。”
And I'm like, OK. I'm already depressed. I'm already feeling bad. When I got off the phone, I was crying. I felt so bad. I'm like, "This is my help? 13 killers, people with no credibility, they're going to help me?"
我心想，好吧。我已经很沮丧了。我已经感觉很糟了。放下电话时，我哭了。我感觉太糟了。我心想：“这就是我的帮手？13个杀手，一群毫无信誉的人，他们要帮我？”
In the end, Monica Childs won her suit against the police department. And finally, sick of the whole thing, she retired from the force. The trouble with doing the right thing, of course, is that often, it is not clear what the right thing is. And just as often, doing the right thing has unintended consequences. Monica Childs worries sometimes about the testimony that got thrown out because she put her foot down. It turns out that that testimony might have cleared another suspect in the crime, a man named Eddie James, who eventually was sentenced to 70 to 150 years for the murder.
最终，莫妮卡·柴尔德斯赢得了对警察局的诉讼。最后，厌倦了这一切，她从警队退休了。做正确的事的麻烦在于，通常很难界定什么是“正确的事”。而且做正确的事往往会有意想不到的后果。莫妮卡·柴尔德斯有时会担心因为她坚持立场而被驳回的证词。事实证明，那份证词本可能洗清该案中另一名嫌疑人埃迪·詹姆斯的嫌疑，他最终因谋杀罪被判处70到150年监禁。
And it just bothers me. And it will probably bother me 'til I die to know that one innocent man is in prison. And it was like, "Damn. How could this happen?"
这困扰着我。只要我活着，想到有一个无辜的人在监狱里，这可能就会一直困扰着我。当时的感觉就是：“该死。怎么会这样？”
And I almost wish I hadn't said anything. But then, it would've been remiss of me to know the truth and not tell it. I did the right thing, but he still got hurt.
我几乎希望我什么都没说。但如果我知道真相却不说出来，那就是我的失职。我做了正确的事，但他还是受到了伤害。
Monica Childs. She spoke with reporter John Bowe, who interviewed her for a book called Gig about people in all sorts of jobs.
莫妮卡·柴尔德斯。她与记者约翰·鲍谈过，后者为一本关于各种职业的书《Gig》采访了她。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "RUN ON"  BY ELVIS PRESLEY]
[音乐响起 - 埃尔维斯·普雷斯利的《RUN ON》]
Act Two-- Money Versus Man. Let's move now from big-city Detroit to small-town Texas for a story where the bad guys aren't murderers. They're real estate developers, and maybe not so bad. They are just doing what God intended for real estate developers to do, which is, of course, come into town, throw around a lot of money, get people all excited.
第二幕——钱与人的较量。现在让我们从大城市底特律转向德克萨斯州的一个小镇，讲述一个坏人不是谋杀犯的故事。他们是房地产开发商，也许没那么坏。他们只是在做上帝希望房地产开发商做的事情，当然，就是来到镇上，挥霍大笔资金，让人们兴奋起来。
In this case, it caused a series of events which cascaded out of control, one after another, until by the end, even the people involved all seemed sort of amazed at how far it went. And in the midst of this, it was yet another person, a government official, trying to do the right thing as he saw it, no matter what. Alix Spiegel tells the story.
在这个案例中，它引发了一系列失控的连锁事件，直到最后，即使是参与其中的人们也对事态的发展感到震惊。而在这一切之中，又是另一个人，一名政府官员，试图坚持他认为正确的事情，无论发生什么。阿利克斯·斯皮格尔讲述了这个故事。
When Scott Bradley moved to Westlake, there were fewer than 10 roads, and several of those were unpaved. This was the '70s. And at the time, this level of development wasn't unusual for the area. It was country, low hills and long grass and not much else, which is why Scott Bradley moved to Westlake. Which is why most people moved to Westlake, they wanted a rural life in a rural place a short commute from the city. Fort Worth, Texas, was only 30 minutes away.
当斯科特·布拉德利搬到韦斯特莱克时，镇上只有不到10条路，其中几条还是未铺设的。那是70年代。当时，这种开发水平在该地区并不罕见。那是乡村，有低矮的山丘和长草，除此之外没别的，这就是斯科特·布拉德利搬到韦斯特莱克的原因。这也是大多数人搬到韦斯特莱克的原因，他们想要在离城市通勤距离不远的地方过乡村生活。德克萨斯州沃思堡距离这里仅30分钟路程。
But then the city grew. By the mid-'80s, suburban sprawl had overtaken most of Westlake's neighbors. There were 7-11s, Home Depots, miles of subdivisions, and all the other clutter you find in any town in any place in America, but not in Westlake. The people in Westlake wanted something different.
但后来城市发展了。到了80年代中期，郊区扩张吞噬了韦斯特莱克的大部分邻居。出现了7-11便利店、家得宝、数英里的细分住宅区，以及你在美国任何地方都能看到的杂乱建筑，但韦斯特莱克没有。韦斯特莱克的人们想要不同的生活。
By 1994, when Scott Bradley became mayor, there was still no real commercial development in town. The town government wouldn't permit it. They knew they couldn't stave off suburban sprawl forever. But everyone, the townspeople, the town council, and especially Mayor Bradley agreed, the at least wanted to try.
到了1994年，当斯科特·布拉德利成为市长时，镇上仍然没有真正的商业开发。镇政府不允许。他们知道他们无法永远抵御郊区的扩张。但每个人，镇民、镇议会，尤其是布拉德利市长都同意，他们至少想尝试一下。
This story begins in 1993, when one of the properties in Westlake, a 2,500-acre ranch called the Circle T, appears on the auction block. This property, which, by the way, was the single largest piece of land in town, and probably the most beautiful undeveloped stretch of real estate within a half-hour commute of the Fort Worth metroplex, then attracts the attention of Ross Perot Jr., son of the former presidential candidate, a high-powered real estate developer, who is quoted in the papers saying that for him, business was about more than win or lose. It was about win or die.
这个故事始于1993年，当时韦斯特莱克的一处房产，一个名为Circle T的2500英亩牧场，出现在拍卖会上。顺便提一下，这处房产是镇上最大的地块，很可能是沃思堡大都市区半小时通勤路程内最美丽的未开发地产，它吸引了罗斯·佩罗二世的注意。他是前总统候选人的儿子，一位极具影响力的房地产开发商，曾在报纸上引用他说，对他而言，生意不仅仅是输赢的问题。是赢还是死的问题。
So Ross Jr. buys the Circle T ranch. And then a couple years later, after a lot of thought and planning, and minimal contact with Westlake's town government, he and his company, the Hillwood corporation, finally present their plans for the development of the Circle T to the citizens of Westlake, all 250 of them. David Brown is a Westlake resident who attended the meeting.
于是罗斯二世买下了Circle T牧场。几年后，经过深思熟虑和规划，以及与韦斯特莱克镇政府的最低限度接触，他和他的公司Hillwood公司终于向韦斯特莱克的全体250名居民展示了Circle T的开发计划。戴维·布朗是参加了会议的韦斯特莱克居民。
Hillwood Development, which is Mr. Perot's company, had a meeting over here in Solana, at a big meeting hall. And they had pictures, drawings, of a beautiful little town that they were going to build. It showed little two-story buildings in the downtown area, and it showed a very pleasant and not too crowded place. And we were all delighted by what we saw in the drawings. But when you read the accompanying 300-page document, you found that it looked like there  was going to be 50,000 people crammed in here.
佩罗先生的公司Hillwood开发公司在这里的索拉纳举行了一次会议，地点在一个大型会议大厅。他们有他们要建造的美丽小镇的照片和图纸。它显示了市中心有两层楼的小建筑，显示了一个非常舒适且不太拥挤的地方。我们对图纸上看到的一切感到高兴。但当你读到随附的300页文件时，你会发现这里似乎要挤进5万人。
The accompanying 300-page document, written in convoluted legal speak, basically gave Perot and his company, the Hillwood corporation, infinite flexibility to do with the town of Westlake as they pleased. The fine print included plans for a regional shopping mall, upscale home apartments, an office park, a golf course, zoning for a sports arena, and more-- $3 billion worth of commercial and residential development with enough room for an additional 50,000 to 80,000 people. Now keep, in mind that this is the kind of community where a visiting reporter, me, for instance, could sit through a city council meeting where a full 40 minutes of heated debate centered on the question of whether the new town sidewalks should be raised half an inch or feathered to the ground so as not to disturb the natural line of the landscape. So predictably, once the residents of Westlake learned the details, they were profoundly disturbed and alarmed. The meeting room was hot, some say close to 100 degrees. But every townsperson stayed to the bitter end. And according to Don Redding, another Westlake resident who attended the presentation, they were all mad as hell about what Perot and the Hillwood Corporation wanted to do.
那份随附的300页文件用复杂的法律术语编写，基本上赋予了佩罗和他的Hillwood公司随心所欲地处置韦斯特莱克镇的无限灵活性。细则包括区域购物中心、高档住宅公寓、办公园区、高尔夫球场、体育场馆的分区规划等等——价值30亿美元的商业和住宅开发项目，有足够的空间容纳额外5万到8万人。请记住，这是一个来访记者（比如我）可以坐在市议会会议中，目睹长达40分钟的热烈辩论，仅仅围绕新镇人行道是应该抬高半英寸还是斜铺到地面，以免破坏景观自然线条的问题。所以可以预见的是，一旦韦斯特莱克居民了解了细节，他们感到深感不安和震惊。会议室很热，有人说接近100华氏度。但每位镇民都坚持到了最后。据另一位参加演示的韦斯特莱克居民唐·雷丁说，他们对佩罗和Hillwood公司想要做的事情感到愤怒极了。
In essence, we would have turned over the community to the developer. In other words, that was the tone of it, is, "All right. I'll take it from here. You people have been in charge, or run the town, up to this point. But from now on, we'll take care of it. We'll make your decisions for you." And that was the whole tone of it.
本质上，我们将把社区交给开发商。换句话说，当时的基调是：“好了。从现在起由我接管。你们这些人到目前为止负责管理小镇。但从现在起，由我们来打理。我们会为你们做决定。”这就是整个基调。
And people didn't like that.
人们不喜欢那样。
No, they didn't care for that too much.
不，他们不太喜欢。
Now at the time Ross Jr. brought his plans for development of the Circle T to the citizens of Westlake, the town was run by six men-- the mayor, Scott Bradley, and five aldermen. Mayor Bradley was a soft-spoken but very successful lawyer with a reputation for staking out the ethical high ground. Meticulous, detail-oriented, Scott liked to stand at city council meetings. Three different people told me that, that Scott Bradley liked to stand at city council meetings. I think the reason they mention it is because the formality of that act, standing up, stood in such sharp contrast to the rest of the city government.
当时罗斯二世将他的开发计划带给韦斯特莱克居民时，镇子由六个人管理——市长斯科特·布拉德利和五名议员。布拉德利市长是一位说话温和但非常成功的律师，以坚守道德高地而闻名。斯科特做事一丝不苟，注重细节，他喜欢在市议会会议上站着。三个人告诉过我，斯科特·布拉德利喜欢在市议会会议上站着。我认为他们提到这一点是因为这种行为的正式感，站立，与城市政府的其他部分形成了鲜明的对比。
The other people on the city council, the aldermen, were not formal people. Al Oien was a retired airplane pilot who wore his overalls to meetings. Fred Held was a third-generation hardware man. There was Caroll Huntress, a former assistant football coach who later got into oil exploration, and Howard Dudley, who was in the chemical business, and Jerry Moore, who owned a tile and carpet company.
市议会的其他人，即议员们，并非正式的人。阿尔·奥伊恩是一位退休飞行员，他穿着工作服参加会议。弗雷德·赫尔德是第三代五金商人。还有卡罗尔·亨特雷斯，一名前助理橄榄球教练，后来从事石油勘探；霍华德·达德利，从事化学行业；以及拥有瓷砖和地毯公司的杰里·摩尔。
I should mention here that being an alderman in Westlake, Texas, was not what you would call a full-time job. For years, the city council meetings were held in the aldermen's living rooms. Even when the city government moved into an official town hall in the early '90s, the meetings retained their living room feeling.
我应该在这里提一下，在德克萨斯州韦斯特莱克做议员并不是所谓的全职工作。多年来，市议会会议都在议员的客厅里举行。即使在90年代初市政府搬进正式的镇政府大楼后，会议依然保留了客厅的感觉。
It was comfortable. It was casual. There was not, in truth, all that much to discuss. Now in light of later events, it's important to be clear on one point. At the time of the Perot presentation, all five of Westlake's aldermen were opposed to the Perot development plan.
那很舒适。很随意。事实上，真的没有那么多需要讨论的事情。鉴于后来的事件，在一点上必须明确。在佩罗展示计划时，韦斯特莱克的五名议员全部反对佩罗的开发计划。
Then something happened, and this consensus came to an end. Ross Jr. made another land purchase in the town of Westlake, 500 acres of Texas prairie on which one of the aldermen, a man named Carroll Huntress, rented a home. It was after this land purchase that suddenly and inexplicably, four of the five aldermen, Al Oien, Jerry Moore, Howard Dudley, and Perot's new tenant, Carroll Huntress, started questioning the town's traditional anti-growth stance. There were a series of uncomfortable town meetings where the four aldermen publicly challenged the mayor, and some statements were made to the local press. Miles Moffeit is a reporter for the Fort Worth Star-Telegram who covered what became the Westlake story.
然后发生了一些事情，这种共识结束了。罗斯二世在韦斯特莱克镇又购买了一块土地，那是500英亩的德克萨斯大草原，其中一名议员，一个叫卡罗尔·亨特雷斯的人在那里租了一栋房子。正是这笔土地购买之后，五名议员中的四名，阿尔·奥伊恩、杰里·摩尔、霍华德·达德利以及佩罗的新房客卡罗尔·亨特雷斯，突然且莫名其妙地开始质疑镇上传统的反增长立场。举行了一系列令人不安的镇民会议，四名议员公开挑战市长，并向当地媒体发表了一些声明。迈尔斯·莫费特是《沃思堡星报》的记者，他报道了后来被称为“韦斯特莱克故事”的事件。
Perot purchased the land Huntress lived on. And almost within weeks, Huntress and these other aldermen were releasing signals that they were tired of the fighting, that it was time for the town to come around to Perot's views. I got an interview with him, and he began explaining that Perot basically can't lose. And Perot is going to have this way eventually anyway, so the town should come around and just start appeasing him.
佩罗购买了亨特雷斯居住的土地。几乎在几周之内，亨特雷斯和其他议员就发出信号，说他们厌倦了争斗，是时候让镇子接受佩罗的观点了。我采访了他，他开始解释说佩罗基本上是不可战胜的。反正佩罗最终都会得逞，所以小镇应该让步并开始安抚他。
This turn was hard to explain. These men, after all, had helped to build the town. For years, they turned away developers with plans much more modest than Perot's. Why would they reverse their decades-long anti-growth stance in a matter of weeks? Rumors circulated around town, theories about payoffs, none of which could be substantiated, none of which satisfied. Meanwhile, Mayor Bradley refused to support the Perot plan, and relations between the four aldermen and the mayor became strained, and then positively hostile. There was a fight over where the town boundaries fell, in which each side accused the other of manipulation and deception. There was an ugly incident between one of the aldermen's wives and some townspeople, and the general sense that things were quickly falling apart. David Brown.
这种转变很难解释。毕竟，这些人帮助建设了这个小镇。多年来，他们拒绝了比佩罗计划温和得多的开发商计划。为什么他们会在几周内扭转几十年的反增长立场？镇上传言四起，关于收受贿赂的理论，但都没有得到证实，也没有人对此满意。与此同时，布拉德利市长拒绝支持佩罗计划，四名议员与市长之间的关系变得紧张，甚至变得积极敌对。在一场关于镇界划分的争斗中，双方互相指责对方操纵和欺骗。其中一名议员的妻子与一些镇民之间发生了丑陋的事件，普遍感觉情况正在迅速恶化。戴维·布朗。
There was a great deal of acrimony between the citizens and the council, and between Bradley and the council. And the citizens, it was even harsher than Bradley. People were calling these guys all kinds of names. Who do you work for? Who's  paying your salary? Who have you sold out to? This sort of thing. And it was pretty hot.
市民与议会之间，以及布拉德利与议会之间，存在着巨大的积怨。市民们甚至比对布拉德利更苛刻。人们在叫这些家伙各种各样的名字。你为谁工作？谁在付你的薪水？你把谁出卖给了谁？就是这种事情。当时的气氛非常火爆。
Reporter Miles Moffeit.
记者迈尔斯·莫费特。
From that point on, it was just pure bedlam. These guys were calling their own meetings. Scott was vetoing every action that they took. It went back and forth and back and forth for weeks, until these former aldermen decided to just put him on trial and remove him from office.
从那时起，简直是一片混乱。这些家伙召开了他们自己的会议。斯科特否决了他们采取的每一项行动。争斗持续了数周，直到这些前议员决定直接对他进行审判并将他免职。
They announced they were going to impeach Mr. Bradley. And I, for one, thought it was a bluff. The legal basis for it was a law passed back in the 1870s that had only been used once or twice, and never since the early 1900s. And I thought, "They'll be laughed out of court."
他们宣布要弹劾布拉德利先生。我个人认为这只是虚张声势。法律依据是一项19世纪70年代通过的法律，该法律仅被使用过一两次，自20世纪初以来从未被使用过。我想，“他们会被人笑死在法庭上。”
Yeah, it was like a 100-year-old statute. And it says that a small town board of aldermen can convene a trial, act as judge, jury, and witness, and remove a colleague from office, be it a mayor or a fellow alderman.
是的，那就像是一条100年前的法规。它规定，小镇的议员委员会可以召开审判，充当法官、陪审团和证人，并将一名同事撤职，无论是市长还是同僚议员。
There were four counts brought against the mayor, two of them so inconsequential that neither the accused mayor nor the prosecuting aldermen can remember what they were. One count charged the mayor with removing a meeting notice which had been posted on the town hall door. The only substantive charge accused him of tricking the aldermen into endorsing a map which expanded the town's boundaries. But most Westlake residents believed that the aldermen wanted to impeach Mayor Bradley for a different reason. The mayor was the most outspoken and intractable opponent of the Perot plan. As mayor, with veto power, it would be impossible for Perot and his company, the Hillwood Corporation, to proceed with development with Bradley standing in the way. When the issue was raised in the local press, Perot denied influencing the aldermen in any way. But a series of actions taken by the aldermen only compounded this view. David Brown.
对市长提起了四项指控，其中两项极其微不足道，以至于被告市长和负责起诉的议员都不记得是什么了。一项指控指责市长移除了张贴在镇政府门上的会议通知。唯一实质性的指控指责他欺骗议员支持了一张扩大镇边界的地图。但大多数韦斯特莱克居民认为，议员们想要弹劾布拉德利市长是出于另一个原因。市长是佩罗计划最直言不讳、最难以对付的反对者。作为市长，拥有否决权，只要布拉德利挡路，佩罗和他的Hillwood公司就不可能继续开发。当这个问题在当地媒体上被提出来时，佩罗否认以任何方式影响了议员。但议员们采取的一系列行动只会加剧这种观点。戴维·布朗。
The next thing they did, they fired the city attorney, who'd been city attorney for 20 or 25 years. They fired the town planner. And they said, "We've made a deal with Hillwood that we're going to use their lawyer and their town planner." Well, you know. And, "The town will get their services for free, and Hillwood will pay for it all." And the new law firm came in, the new lawyer from a law firm up in Denton came in. And he immediately began to orchestrate Bradley's trial.
接下来他们做的事情是，解雇了已经担任了20或25年城市律师的市检察官。他们解雇了城镇规划师。他们说：“我们已经与Hillwood达成了协议，我们将使用他们的律师和他们的城镇规划师。”嗯，你知道的。而且，“镇子将免费获得他们的服务，Hillwood将支付所有费用。”新的律师事务所进来了，来自丹顿的一家律师事务所的新律师进来了。他立即开始策划布拉德利的审判。
David Brown presented the aldermen with a petition signed by 125 Westlake residents, half the town's population, which condemned their move to oust Mayor Bradley. As the aldermen's lawyers prepared to put the mayor on trial, Scott Bradley and his supporters began to meet regularly to strategize about how to counteract the actions of the aldermen. They would gather in their own homes, in their living rooms or private offices. And as they did this, they started noticing a strange thing was happening. This is Don Redding.
戴维·布朗向议员们提交了一份由125名韦斯特莱克居民（镇上一半人口）签署的请愿书，谴责他们驱逐布拉德利市长的举动。当议员们的律师准备对市长进行审判时，斯科特·布拉德利和他的支持者开始定期聚会，商讨如何对抗议员们的行动。他们会在自己家里、客厅或私人办公室里聚集。当他们这样做时，他们开始注意到一件奇怪的事情正在发生。这是唐·雷丁。
All I can tell you is in meetings that were held where there might be three or four or five people in attendance, that I was quoted from that meeting the next day from somebody that had no way of knowing what went on, in the exact words and in the exact sequence that were made in that meeting.
我只能告诉你，在可能只有三四个人出席的会议上，第二天我就听到有人引用了那次会议上的话，那人根本不可能知道会上发生了什么，甚至连确切的措辞和顺序都一模一样。
Ruby Held, wife of Alderman Fred Held, the only alderman who continued to support Mayor Bradley.
露比·赫尔德，继续支持布拉德利市长的议员弗雷德·赫尔德的妻子。
Whatever we planned, they beat us to whatever we planned. So we know we were being watched. We were being listened to. Somehow, they were monitoring our phone calls.
无论我们计划什么，他们总是比我们早一步知道。所以我们知道我们被监视了。我们被偷听了。不知何故，他们在监听我们的电话。
This is Mayor Scott Bradley.
这是斯科特·布拉德利市长。
Well, we all started, number one, nobody would talk on a hard telephone. We would go to other telephones to talk. Or we would talk on the digital cell phones. I myself would take my digital phone out by the fountain.
好吧，我们都开始了，第一点，没人会在座机上说话。我们会去别的电话那里说话。或者我们会在数字手机上说话。我自己会带着数字手机到喷泉旁边去。
Reporter Miles Moffeit.
记者迈尔斯·莫费特。
They held secret meetings out in the woods. And they would pass around notes. And they couldn't carry on a conversation with the blinds open.
他们在树林里举行秘密会议。他们会传递纸条。他们无法在百叶窗打开的情况下进行对话。
Don Redding.
唐·雷丁。
We'd even drive as far as a quarter of a mile away from my home and meet with them on the side of a road. Did that on several occasions. And this is really interesting when you understand that in the early '70s, I worked in the Soviet Union for IBM. And that was one of the most closed societies in the world. The KGB was with us always. And I frankly felt more threatened here than I did when I worked in the Soviet Union.
我们甚至会开车离开家四分之一英里远，在路边与他们会面。这种情况发生过好几次。当你理解我在70年代初曾在苏联为IBM工作时，这真的很有趣。那是世界上最封闭的社会之一。克格勃总是跟着我们。坦白说，我觉得在这里比我在苏联工作时感到的威胁还要大。
You felt more threatened here than you did-- you felt like you were being watched more?
你觉得在这里比在那里受到的威胁更大——你觉得你被监视得更厉害？
Absolutely, no question about it in my mind. You can call that as paranoid, but it's only paranoid when it's not happening. And in this case, I was convinced it was.
绝对，我心中毫无疑问。你可以称之为偏执，但只有在事情没发生时才叫偏执。在这种情况下，我确信它正在发生。
Ruby Held was out in her yard one day. She was birdwatching, she says, to calm her nerves. She was tracking a bird with her binoculars. It flew across the street. And as she turned to follow it, she noticed there was a van driving slowly back and forth in front of her home. The van had two people in it, and they too had binoculars. They were looking right back at her. Miles Moffeit.
有一天，露比·赫尔德在院子里。她说她在观鸟，为了平复紧张的情绪。她用双筒望远镜跟踪一只鸟。它飞过了马路。当她转头追随它时，她注意到有一辆面包车在她家门前慢慢地来回行驶。车里有两个人，他们也有双筒望远镜。他们也在回看她。迈尔斯·莫费特。
Well, she got the tag number. And we ran a check and discovered that this van belonged to a private investigation service in Irving. And their names were Jerry and Cherry Davis.
好吧，她记下了车牌号。我们进行了一次查询，发现这辆面包车属于欧文市的一家私人调查服务公司。他们的名字叫杰里和切里·戴维斯。
I got on the phone with one of the detectives, and he acknowledged having worked for Perot's law firm at one point, then kept the conversation really short. So the depositions later on reflect that there were indeed investigators hired to track Bradley. But it's just real difficult to tell who hired them.
我给其中一名侦探打了电话，他承认曾经为佩罗的律师事务所工作过，然后就把谈话缩得很短。所以后来的证词反映出确实有调查人员受雇追踪布拉德利。但真的很难说是谁雇了他们。
Perot denies hiring private detectives to track his opponents in Westlake. He and his development company, the Hillwood Corporation, declined to be interviewed for this story. But Miles Moffeit, who has covered Perot Jr.'s business dealings, both inside and outside Westlake for a number of years, says the notion that Perot would have his opponent tailed is not completely outlandish.
佩罗否认雇佣私人侦探追踪他在韦斯特莱克的对手。他和他的开发公司Hillwood公司拒绝接受关于此事的采访。但报道过佩罗二世多年来在韦斯特莱克内外商业往来的迈尔斯·莫费特表示，佩罗会跟踪他的对手这种想法并不完全是荒唐的。
Perot's-- the way he goes about his business is generally very stealthy. And he acknowledges that, to him, business is war. And in order to understand this perspective, you have to understand that stealth and aggressiveness are just two very important factors in going to war. A town of 250 people just had a very difficult time keeping up.
佩罗——他处理生意的方式通常非常隐蔽。他承认，对他来说，生意就是战争。为了理解这种观点，你必须明白隐秘和进取是参与战争的两个非常重要的因素。一个250人的小镇很难跟得上。
Then there was another thing which fanned the flames of the town's fear of Ross Perot Jr.-- a book called Citizen Perot written by journalist Gerald Posner. Now, this book is not about Ross Perot Jr. It's about his father, the former presidential candidate. It's an unauthorized biography which includes a chapter called "I'm not an investigative personality," about Ross Sr.'s now-famous obsession with security, and his use of private investigators and security teams in his business dealings. Ruby Held.
还有另一件事助长了该镇对罗斯·佩罗二世的恐惧——一本名为《公民佩罗》的书，由记者杰拉尔德·波斯纳撰写。这本书不是关于罗斯·佩罗二世的。它是关于他父亲的，即前总统候选人。这是一本未经授权的传记，其中包含一章名为“我不是调查型人格”的内容，关于老佩罗现在著名的对安全的痴迷，以及他在商业交易中使用私人调查员和安保团队。露比·赫尔德。
There was some chapters I went for three weeks. I couldn't even read between-- I couldn't pick it up again. I thought, "I can't believe what this man has done." And because, I think, I had read that book, it gave us-- something would come up in city council. Or they'd come in, and everything they did was, I'd say, "That's chapter six," or "This is chapter two."
有些章节我看了三周。我甚至无法读完——我无法再把它拿起来。我想，“我不敢相信这个人做了什么。”因为，我认为，我读过那本书，它给了我们——市议会上发生了一些事情。或者他们进来了，他们做的一切，我会说：“那是第六章，”或者“这是第二章。”
Every single home I visited in Westlake had a copy of Citizen Perot, well-worn, full of underlining and scribbled notes in the margins, whole passages outlined in yellow highlight. The more they read, the more worried and hysterical they became. It is in this climate of paranoia that the aldermen put Mayor Scott Bradley on trial. It was held on a Tuesday in the cafeteria of the Solana office complex, which housed the town hall. The mayor's supporters plastered the walls with posters of the Declaration of Independence and the US Constitution. David Brown.
我访问过的韦斯特莱克每一户人家都有一本《公民佩罗》，读得很破旧，满是划线和边缘潦草的笔记，整段整段的内容用黄色荧光笔标出。他们读得越多，就越担忧和歇斯底里。正是在这种偏执的气氛中，议员们审判了斯科特·布拉德利市长。审判是在周二在镇政府所在的索拉纳办公大楼的食堂里举行的。市长的支持者在墙上贴满了《独立宣言》和美国宪法的海报。戴维·布朗。
I guess the whole town was there, plus maybe 200 or 300 other people. It was a big crowd that came out, even though it was 10 o'clock on a weekday. And Mr. Huntress was chairman of the court. The town council, the aldermen, sat as the court, all five of them, even though they had brought the charges. And even though one or two of them testified against Bradley at the trial, they were still allowed to vote as judges.
我想全镇的人都在那儿，外加大约200或300人。即使是工作日的上午10点，也来了很多人。亨特雷斯先生是法庭的主席。镇议会，即议员们，作为法庭坐着，一共五个人，尽管是他们提出的指控。即使他们中的一两个人在审判中作证反对布拉德利，他们仍然被允许作为法官投票。
Miles Moffeit.
迈尔斯·莫费特。
The aldermen had set themselves up along this long table. And in the middle was an attorney named Bill Wood, who had done some work for Perot.
议员们把自己排在那张长桌边。中间坐着一位名叫比尔·伍德的律师，他曾经为佩罗做过一些工作。
Don Redding.
唐·雷丁。
And it was kind of curious because when something would be posed that Huntress didn't know how to handle, which was most of it, he would look to this attorney. And the attorney would try to advise him. It was such a ludicrous thing. And it was such a staged thing that there was no question about what was going to happen.
这很奇怪，因为当出现亨特雷斯不知道如何处理的问题（大部分都是这种情况）时，他会看向这位律师。律师会试图建议他。这太滑稽了。这是一场安排好的戏，毫无疑问会发生什么。
Ruby Held.
露比·赫尔德。
I'm sitting there thinking, "I must be in Russia." I cannot believe they're sitting up and testifying against him and judging him and being the jury, all in one fell swoop. I thought, "This must be the way they railroad somebody in Russia and put them in prison, because this is the biggest trumped-up farce I've ever seen in my whole life." My whole insides felt like they were boiling.
我坐在那儿想，“我一定是在俄罗斯。”我无法相信他们坐起来，既作证反对他，又审判他，还要充当陪审团，这一切都在一次突袭中完成。我想，“这一定就是他们在俄罗斯整垮某人并把他们关进监狱的方式，因为这是我一生中见过的最大的假戏。”我整个内心感觉都在沸腾。
After a 15-minute break for deliberation, the board, in a four to one vote, with Fred Held dissenting, found Scott Bradley guilty as charged and dismissed him as mayor of the city of Westlake. The crowd booed. Scott Bradley.
经过15分钟的审议，委员会以四比一的投票结果（弗雷德·赫尔德持异议），判定斯科特·布拉德利罪名成立，并免除了他的韦斯特莱克市长职务。人群发出嘘声。斯科特·布拉德利。
When the verdict was read, my lawyer stood up and said, "Is that your verdict?" And they said, "Yes, it is." And he said, "When are you going to put it into effect?" And they said, "Right now." And my lawyer says, "Right now?" And Carroll Huntress said, "Right now," and proceeded to sign the papers that Bill Wood furnished him.
判决宣读时，我的律师站起来说：“这就是你们的判决吗？”他们说：“是的。”他说：“你们什么时候执行？”他们说：“现在。”我的律师说：“现在？”卡罗尔·亨特雷斯说：“现在，”并着手签署了比尔·伍德提供的文件。
And I can't remember exactly how it happened. But there was a defining moment, where it was just a spontaneous applause, essentially aimed at my lawyer and me for having gone through this terrible situation. And I was so moved that I stood up, and I applauded the audience for having gone through this whole thing.
我不记得具体是怎么发生的。但有一个决定性的时刻，那是自发的掌声，基本上是针对我和我的律师，因为我们经历了这种可怕的情况。我深受感动，以至于我站起来，为观众经历这一切而鼓掌。
Immediately after the trial, Bradley got in the car and drove to the district courthouse to file an appeal. But en route, he got a call on his cell phone. It was from one of the townspeople, a woman staked out at the town hall who told Bradley that the aldermen had posted another notice which announced yet another meeting. Scott Bradley.
审判结束后，布拉德利立即上车前往地区法院提出上诉。但在路上，他接到了手机电话。是一个镇民打来的，一个守在镇政府大楼外的妇女，她告诉布拉德利议员们贴出了另一份通知，宣布将举行另一次会议。斯科特·布拉德利。
She had copied enough of it that she was able to read it to us. And it became very apparent then what was happening. They were going to blow the town up.
她抄下了足够多的内容，能够读给我们听。事情变得非常明显。他们要毁掉这个镇。
The aldermen's notice, posted three hours after the impeachment of Mayor Scott Bradley, proposed the disannexation of 90% of the town of Westlake. 90% of the city's property would be transferred to neighboring communities, and the town would essentially be disbanded, simply given away. Included in the disannexation ordinance were all lands belonging to Ross Perot Jr., and the three properties owned by the aldermen. Reporter Miles Moffeit.
议员们的通知在斯科特·布拉德利市长被弹劾后三小时贴出，提议取消韦斯特莱克90%土地的并入。该市90%的财产将被转移到邻近社区，镇子将基本上被解散，直接送人。取消并入条例中包括所有属于罗斯·佩罗二世的土地，以及议员们拥有的三处房产。记者迈尔斯·莫费特。
Everybody was like, "OK, they're just going to blow up the town." On paper, it would look as though the town was blown up. There's just pieces, far-flung pieces attached by very thin strips of land.
每个人都像是在说：“好吧，他们要把镇子炸飞了。”在纸面上，看起来就像镇子被炸毁了。只剩下一些零散的、通过狭窄土地连接的碎片。
Word of the posting spread quickly. And within half an hour, a small army of citizens had gathered at the town hall, most too stunned to observe what was happening. The properties belonging to the aldermen and Perot were eventually released to the city of Fort Worth, in exchange for a promise that they would pay no property taxes for a minimum of 15 years. Here's David Brown, Don Redding, and Scott Bradley.
通知的消息迅速传开。半小时内，一小队市民聚集在镇政府大楼，大多数人惊呆了，无法观察正在发生什么。属于议员和佩罗的房产最终被移交给沃思堡市，以换取他们承诺至少15年不缴纳财产税。这里是戴维·布朗、唐·雷丁和斯科特·布拉德利。
I was incredulous. I said, "They can't be doing-- this is not sane."
我难以置信。我说：“他们不能这样做——这不理智。”
You had no idea that anybody would have been considered something like this. It's like, this is unbelievable. Really, you're just astounded.
你根本没想到有人会考虑这样的事情。这简直令人难以置信。真的，你只是感到震惊。
I really couldn't make any sense of it. I wasn't there, but it had to be very much akin to the feeling of people observing the Oklahoma City bombing. It was a senseless act. It brought only harm and devastation. And this is the same feeling I had, that it just seemed to be the work of madmen.
我真的无法理解。我不在那里，但这一定非常像人们观察俄克拉荷马城爆炸案的感觉。这是一个愚蠢的行为。它只带来了伤害和破坏。这是我有的同样的感受，它看起来只是疯子的所作所为。
Coming up, are madmen actually smarter than the rest of us? Are people with money? Or do they just plan things out better? Alix Spiegel's story from Westlake, Texas, continues in a minute from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，疯子真的比我们其余人更聪明吗？有钱人呢？还是他们只是把事情计划得更好？阿利克斯·斯皮格尔从德克萨斯州韦斯特莱克带来的故事将在来自国际公共广播电台的一分钟后继续，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, bring you various stories on that theme. Today's program, for the July 4 holiday, stories of idealists in American government two centuries after the first independence day, and answers to this question. Can you fight city hall if you are city hall?
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种故事。今天的节目是7月4日假期特辑，关于美国政府理想主义者的故事，距离第一个独立日两个世纪后，以及这个问题的答案：如果你就是市政府，你还能对抗市政府吗？
We're in the middle of Alix Spiegel's story from Westlake, Texas. The mayor has been thrown out of office. A notice is posted calling for a meeting in which the town would give away most of its land to other towns. At this point, Mayor Scott Bradley went to district court to have them issue an order so his impeachment would not take effect right away.
我们正在进行阿利克斯·斯皮格尔关于德克萨斯州韦斯特莱克的故事。市长已被免职。贴出了一份通知，要求举行会议，镇子将把大部分土地送给其他城镇。此时，斯科特·布拉德利市长前往地区法院，要求他们发布命令，以便他的弹劾不会立即生效。
At the district court, the judge suspended a murder trial for an entire day to issue a ruling favorable to Mayor Bradley, a temporary restraining order which prevented the aldermen from enforcing Bradley's impeachment. The aldermen's lawyers were also present, and they indicated to the district judge that they wanted to appeal his decision to the Fort Worth Court of Appeals in the morning. Mayor Scott Bradley.
在地区法院，法官暂停了一起谋杀案的审判，整整一天，发布了一项有利于布拉德利市长的裁决，这是一个临时限制令，阻止议员们执行对布拉德利的弹劾。议员们的律师也在场，他们向地区法官表示，他们想在早上向沃思堡上诉法院上诉他的决定。斯科特·布拉德利市长。
The judge says, "Fine. I'll order my clerks to stay here, prepare the record. You can come by at," I think he said, "a quarter of eight and pick it up." So as far as we knew, we were going to the court of appeals the next morning.
法官说：“好。我会命令我的书记员待在这里，准备记录。你们可以在，”我想他说，“七点一刻过来领取。”所以据我们所知，我们第二天早上要去上诉法院。
That night, Carroll Huntress and these lawyers get into a car. They drive to one of the justices' homes. They sit in his living room while he talks to two other justices, and comes out and announces that he's going to stay the orders of the district court.
那天晚上，卡罗尔·亨特雷斯和这些律师上了一辆车。他们开车去了其中一名大法官的家。他们坐在他的客厅里，而他与另外两名大法官交谈，然后出来宣布他将暂缓地区法院的命令。
And so in a late-night hearing in a judge's living room, the impeachment of Scott Bradley was reinstated. David Brown.
于是，在一场深夜在法官客厅举行的听证会上，斯科特·布拉德利的弹劾被恢复了。戴维·布朗。
It happened very quickly. The district court order came out about 5 o'clock. And by 11 o'clock that night, it had been overturned by the court of appeals.
事情发生得非常快。地区法院的命令大约在5点发出。到了那天晚上11点，它就被上诉法院推翻了。
Again, this made us feel we are really up against it. If people have that much clout, they can go to an appeals court in the middle of the night. If I were a private citizen, and I wanted to get a district court order overturned, I could not go knock on an appeals court judge's door at 9 o'clock at night and say, "Would you please overturn this decision? I know you haven't had time to hear the opponent's side to it, but please overturn it anyway."
同样，这让我们觉得我们真的处于困境中。如果人们有那么大的势力，他们可以在半夜去上诉法院。如果我是普通公民，我想推翻地区法院的命令，我不能在晚上9点敲上诉法院法官的门，说：“请你推翻这个决定好吗？我知道你还没时间听对方的意见，但请还是推翻它。”
I couldn't do that. I doubt anybody in the state could. Or very few people, obviously somebody could, because they did.
我做不到。我怀疑州里没人能做到。或者很少有人，显然有人能，因为他们做到了。
Scott Bradley appealed to the Texas Supreme Court, saying the court of appeals was wrong to make this decision in the middle of the night without hearing his side of the case. And as other lawsuits involving Westlake worked their way to the court of appeals, Mayor Bradley filed another motion. This one said that the court of appeals judges shouldn't be hearing another case involving him, given how they'd handled the impeachment decision and given the fact that he was arguing to the supreme court that they had acted improperly.
斯科特·布拉德利向德克萨斯州最高法院上诉，称上诉法院在没有听取他一方案件的情况下，在半夜做出这个决定是错误的。随着涉及韦斯特莱克的其他诉讼进入上诉法院，布拉德利市长提交了另一项动议。这项动议称，上诉法院法官不应该审理涉及他的另一项案件，鉴于他们处理弹劾决定的方式，以及他正在向最高法院辩称他们行为不当的事实。
This so infuriated the court that they again, without inviting me to be present or giving me any notice they were doing so, convened the entire Fort Worth Court of Appeals and issued a 21-page opinion in which they essentially call my lawyers liars and unfit for the practice of law for filing this motion, and referred them to the General Counsel of the State Bar of Texas to have their license removed. And it had personal repercussions for me, because immediately Cantey and Hanger, the law firm I was working for, call me in. And they said, "We have this $204 million judgment that we're afraid that the same panel that you've said may be biased is going to decide our appeal unfavorably in retribution. So we want you to resign from the law firm."
这激怒了法院，他们再次在没有邀请我在场或没有给我任何通知的情况下，召集了整个沃思堡上诉法院，并发布了一份21页的意见书，本质上称我的律师是撒谎者，不适合从事法律职业，并将其移交给德克萨斯州律师协会总法律顾问，以吊销他们的执照。这对我个人产生了影响，因为坎蒂和汉格律师事务所（我工作的律师事务所）立即召见了我。他们说：“我们有这项2.04亿美元的判决，我们担心你所说的可能有偏见的同一个小组会因为报复而做出不利于我们上诉的决定。所以我们要你从律师事务所辞职。”
And that's how Scott Bradley lost his job. Publicly, Perot continued to deny any involvement in the disintegration of Westlake and portrayed the affair as a local power struggle, a personality conflict between Scott Bradley and the Board of Aldermen. Three days after the impeachment, on Friday, May 2, one evening before the town elections were scheduled, town elections which could change the balance of power on the board, the citizens of Westlake once again gathered in Town Hall, this time to witness the dismantling of their community. With Bradley removed from office, there was no mayor to preside, so prior to the meeting, the aldermen appointed their own mayor, one of the oldest citizens in town. Again, reporter Miles Moffeit.
这就是斯科特·布拉德利失去工作的方式。公开场合，佩罗继续否认参与韦斯特莱克的瓦解，并将此事描述为一场当地权力斗争，一场斯科特·布拉德利和议员委员会之间的人格冲突。弹劾三天后，即5月2日星期五，预定镇选举的前一天晚上（这次选举本可以改变委员会的权力平衡），韦斯特莱克的市民再次聚集在镇政府大楼，这一次是见证他们社区的拆解。布拉德利被免职后，没有市长主持，所以会议前，议员们任命了他们自己的市长，镇上最年长的市民之一。再次，记者迈尔斯·莫费特。
His name was Dale White. And he was almost like a hermit. You didn't see him around town. But suddenly, here he was, the mayor of Westlake.
他的名字叫戴尔·怀特。他几乎像个隐士。你在镇上看不到他。但突然之间，他成了韦斯特莱克的市长。
Once again, the aldermen took their place at the table in front of the room. The meeting was, by all accounts, a very efficient, no-frills process. Most of the actual legal documentation for the disannexations were provided by a lawyer who was working with Perot and the Hillwood Corporation. The aldermen and the new mayor, Dale White, said very little. Much of what they did say, they read from index cards, which had been prepared in advance. Don Redding.
议员们再次坐在会议室前面的桌子旁。根据所有人的说法，会议是一个非常高效、没有多余内容的程序。大部分用于取消并入的实际法律文件是由一名与佩罗和Hillwood公司合作的律师提供的。议员们和新市长戴尔·怀特说的很少。他们说的大部分内容都是从提前准备好的索引卡上读出来的。唐·雷丁。
Through the whole thing, people are trying to object, trying to get them to listen to them. And it's like you might as well not have been in the room. They won't look at you. They won't look at you.
在整个过程中，人们试图反对，试图让他们听取意见。就好像你根本没在房间里一样。他们不看你。他们不看你。
They won't look at you?
他们不看你？
No.
不。
Scott Bradley.
斯科特·布拉德利。
That was probably the lowest point, emotionally, in my life, sitting through that meeting, watching these aldermen. And they literally dismantled the town in about a two-and-a-half-hour period, using documents that Perot's lawyers had prepared.
那可能是我一生中情绪最低落的时刻，坐着参加那次会议，看着这些议员。他们在大约两个半小时的时间里，利用佩罗律师准备的文件，从字面上拆毁了这个镇。
When the last paper was signed, and the town of Westlake officially dismantled, the newly appointed mayor, Dale White, mayor of a town that now did not include the property where he himself lived, in other words, mayor of a town in which he did not hold residence, sat at the table in the front of the room and made the statement which would appear in every newspaper article which covered the story. Scott Bradley.
当最后一份文件签署，韦斯特莱克镇正式解体时，新任命的市长戴尔·怀特（一个连他自己住的财产都不在其中的镇的市长，换句话说，他不是该镇的居民）坐在会议室前面的桌子旁，发表了那句出现在每一篇报道此事的报纸文章中的声明。斯科特·布拉德利。
There were some maps displayed. And several citizens gathered around Dale, upset, and were asking him, "Was this tract in, or is this tract out? Is my property in or is it out?"
展示了一些地图。几位市民围在戴尔身边，感到不安，问他：“这块土地在里面吗，还是在外面？我的财产在里面吗，还是在外面？”
And somebody said, "What do you call this now?" And it seemed like, without thinking, he said, "Perot Town." It was in response to somebody's comment. And he said, "This is Perotville now."
有人说，“你现在叫它什么？”似乎他没经过思考就说：“佩罗镇。”那是对某人评论的回应。他说：“这现在是佩罗维尔了。”
And people looked very shocked at him. And he realized that he had made a very unpolitical statement. And you could see by his actions that he thought, "Oh, man. I've screwed this up to a fare-thee-well."
人们非常震惊地看着他。他意识到自己发表了一个非常不政治的声明。你可以从他的行动中看出他心想，“哦，天哪。我把这事搞得一团糟。”
David Brown.
戴维·布朗。
I went to bed that night thinking, "Man, the town's destroyed." And the next morning at 6:00 AM, on a Saturday morning, when the Fort Worth City Council meets, an emergency session, and claims all the land that had been disannexed from Westlake-- now you don't get the Fort Worth City Council out of bed at 6 o'clock on a Saturday morning unless you have some clout. And yeah, we were mad. We were confused. And we were afraid we might have lost the whole ballgame at that point.
那天晚上我上床睡觉，心想，“天哪，镇子被毁了。”第二天早上6点，在一个周六早上，当沃思堡市议会召开紧急会议时，他们声称拥有所有从韦斯特莱克取消并入的土地——你如果在周六早上6点把沃思堡市议会从床上叫起来，除非你很有势力。是的，我们很愤怒。我们很困惑。我们担心在那一点上我们可能输掉了整场球赛。
The aldermen, naturally, have a very different version of these events, a version they shared with me in a hotel conference room several miles outside of Westlake. It was the first time they'd collected to speak publicly about what had happened. And they insisted that they all be interviewed together. According to the aldermen, they are the true victims of this story, people unjustly accused of selling out the town, when in fact, they were simply trying to protect Westlake from a corrupt and power-hungry mayor, someone so narrow-minded and fanatical about preserving the rural integrity of his community that he rejected a proposal which was in step with the overall goals of Westlake and its citizens. Former Alderman Al Oien.
议员们自然有对这些事件截然不同的版本，他们在韦斯特莱克外几英里的酒店会议室里与我分享了这个版本。这是他们第一次聚集在一起公开谈论发生的事情。他们坚持要求一起接受采访。据议员们说，他们才是这个故事中真正的受害者，人们被错误地指责出卖了这个镇，而事实上，他们只是试图保护韦斯特莱克免受一位腐败且渴望权力的市长的侵害，那个人在保护社区农村完整性方面如此狭隘和狂热，以至于他拒绝了一个符合韦斯特莱克及其公民总体目标的提案。前议员阿尔·奥伊恩。
Our attitude, everyone except one Alderman and this phony mayor we had said, "It's going to change. The best we can hope for is a reasonable change, some input into the change, rather than let them go crazy." And Perot's proposition, it's magnificent. We were really fortunate to have someone with integrity that would develop a town in a reasonable manner, rather than just go in and destroy the thing like most towns develop.
我们的态度（除了一位议员和这位我们有的假市长之外的所有人）是：“它会改变的。我们能希望的最好结果是合理的改变，对改变有一些投入，而不是让他们发疯。”而佩罗的提议是宏大的。我们真的很幸运能有这样一个有诚信的人，以合理的方式开发一个镇，而不是像大多数镇开发那样进去就把东西毁了。
They say they took no bribes from Perot, were never in any way influenced by Perot, but reached their decision to impeach Mayor Bradley after it became clear that he would do anything, including impeding the legal workings of the board, to stop a legitimate businessman with legitimate rights from developing a property which was his own. They described in great detail a series of small battles between themselves and the mayor which led to their decision to impeach him. And listening to them, it does seem possible that what happened in Westlake is that there were some relatively modest misunderstandings and disagreements between the council and Bradley, problems they might have ironed out in normal times.
他们说他们没有从佩罗那里拿任何贿赂，没有以任何方式受到佩罗的影响，但在明确布拉德利市长会做任何事情（包括阻碍委员会的合法运作）来阻止一位拥有合法权利的合法商人开发他自己的财产后，他们做出了弹劾布拉德利的决定。他们详细描述了他们与市长之间导致他们做出弹劾决定的一系列小冲突。听他们说，韦斯特莱克发生的事情确实可能是议会和布拉德利之间存在一些相对适度的误解和分歧，这些问题他们本可以在正常时期解决。
But with the question of Perot's development plan hanging over their heads, these disputes simply spiraled out of control, as each side dug in its heels. The aldermen had run the town for years, and they weren't used to anyone disagreeing with them so persistently and effectively. It was no wonder they came to hate Bradley.
但随着佩罗开发计划的问题悬在他们头上，这些争端只是失控了，因为双方都坚持立场。议员们多年来一直在管理这个镇，他们不习惯有人如此坚持且有效地不同意他们。难怪他们开始憎恨布拉德利。
As for the disannexation of Westlake's land, the aldermen say the hostilities from Westlake's citizens was so great after the trial, they simply felt they had no alternative. They had an opportunity to release themselves from a bad situation, to release the Perot property from unreasonable governance, and they took it. But they don't agree that it was their fault that Westlake was destroyed. Alderman Carroll Huntress.
至于韦斯特莱克土地的取消并入，议员们说审判后韦斯特莱克市民的敌意太大了，他们只是觉得别无选择。他们有机会让自己从糟糕的情况下解脱出来，让佩罗的财产摆脱不合理的治理，他们抓住了机会。但他们不认为韦斯特莱克被毁是他们的错。议员卡罗尔·亨特雷斯。
In essence, they've destroyed the town, when they more or less changed allegiances and had no concern for us whatsoever. They did after the trial. They scorned at you and made harsh remarks at you and treat you like dogs, really.
本质上，是他们毁了这个镇，当他们或多或少改变了忠诚，根本不关心我们。审判后他们做了。他们鄙视你，对你说严厉的话，真的像对待狗一样对待你。
Whatever the aldermen's motivations, the people of Westlake clearly disapproved of their actions. The aldermen had scheduled the disannexation meeting for one night before the regular town elections, presumably because they understood that after the impeachment trial, there was very little chance they would continue in office. They were right. Of the two aldermen eligible for reelection, one withdrew from the race. The other was turned out of office in a landslide vote.
无论议员的动机是什么，韦斯特莱克的人们显然不赞成他们的行为。议员们将取消并入会议定在镇选举前一天晚上，大概是因为他们明白在弹劾审判后，他们继续任职的机会微乎其微。他们是对的。在两名有资格连任的议员中，一人退出了竞选。另一人在压倒性的投票中被赶下台。
Initially, the anti-Perot forces assumed the election, which gave them a majority voting bloc on the Board of Aldermen, would end the political troubles in Westlake. But two days after the election, the old Board of Aldermen posted yet another notice, this one stating that according to their interpretation of Texas election law, the new council was prohibited from assuming office for an additional five business days. During that time, the old board held a series of meetings in which they confirmed the property disannexations, passed an indemnity ordinance to protect themselves from any litigation relating to town matters, and as a final act, disannexed the property which housed Town Hall.
最初，反佩罗势力认为这次选举（让他们在议员委员会中拥有多数投票权）将结束韦斯特莱克的政治麻烦。但在选举两天后，旧的议员委员会又贴出了一份通知，声明根据他们对德克萨斯州选举法的解释，新议会禁止在额外五个工作日内就职。在此期间，旧委员会举行了一系列会议，确认了房产的取消并入，通过了一项赔偿条例以保护自己免受任何与镇事务有关的诉讼，并作为最后一项行为，取消了镇政府大楼所在地的并入。
Meanwhile Bradley, who refused to recognize the validity of his ouster, met regularly with the new board and systematically reversed every action taken by the old board. David Brown.
与此同时，布拉德利拒绝承认他被罢免的合法性，定期与新委员会会面，并系统地推翻了旧委员会采取的每一项行动。戴维·布朗。
We had the old Board of Aldermen refusing to give up their seats, and the new Board of Aldermen a meeting separately and claiming they were the legal board. We had Mayor Bradley claiming he'd been removed from office illegally, and therefore, he was still the legal mayor. And we had the old council and Dale White claiming that Dale White was mayor, because he'd been appointed by the council to replace Mr. Bradley. So anyway, we had two mayors, two councils, and a town that effectively had been destroyed. And it was a mess right at that point.
我们有旧议员委员会拒绝放弃他们的席位，而新议员委员会分别开会，并声称他们是合法委员会。我们有布拉德利市长声称他被非法免职，因此他仍然是合法的市长。我们有旧议会和戴尔·怀特声称戴尔·怀特是市长，因为他被议会任命来接替布拉德利先生。总之，在那一点上我们有两个市长，两个议会，和一个实际上已经被毁掉的镇子。那真是个烂摊子。
Two mayors, two boards, and all for a town which technically didn't exist. Naturally, it got worse. Alderman Carroll Huntress, who didn't have the legal authority to sign city checks greater than $1,000, used a loophole in city policy and wrote 67 $1,000 checks to pay off the legal bills associated with the mayor's impeachment, forcing the town to freeze its bank accounts and declare temporary bankruptcy. Dale White, who continued to claim that he was the rightful mayor of Westlake, changed the locks on the City Hall to keep Bradley and his supporters out. And Bradley, who also continued to claim that he was the rightful mayor of Westlake, changed the locks back.
两个市长，两个议会，全都是为了一个技术上不存在的镇子。自然，情况变得更糟了。没有签署超过1000美元支票法律授权的议员卡罗尔·亨特雷斯，利用城市政策的漏洞，写了67张1000美元的支票来支付与市长弹劾相关的法律费用，迫使镇子冻结银行账户并宣布临时破产。继续声称自己是韦斯特莱克合法市长的戴尔·怀特更换了镇政府大楼的锁，以阻止布拉德利和他的支持者进入。而同样继续声称自己是韦斯特莱克合法市长的布拉德利又把锁换了回来。
In the end, the question of whether or not Westlake would continue to exist was settled in a way that no one could have ever predicted. In the summer of 1998, rumors started circulating around town that a Fortune 500 company was interested in buying a portion of Perot's land in Westlake. They wanted to build a corporate campus and were willing to pay big, but only if certain conditions were met. The company wanted the dispute between Perot and the town resolved. They didn't want the land they bought to fall within the jurisdiction of the city of Fort Worth, one of the land dispute cases then in front of the courts.
最终，韦斯特莱克是否继续存在的问题以一种无人能预料到的方式得到了解决。1998年夏天，镇上传出谣言，称一家财富500强公司有兴趣购买韦斯特莱克佩罗土地的一部分。他们想建立一个企业园区，愿意付出高价，但只有在满足某些条件的情况下。该公司希望解决佩罗与镇子之间的纠纷。他们不希望他们购买的土地落入沃思堡市的司法管辖区内，那是当时法院审理的土地纠纷案件之一。
And there was one other thing. The land they were most interested in buying merged with Mayor Scott Bradley's property. And they wouldn't buy any land unless Bradley also agreed to sell. Perot badly wanted the money. And this put Bradley in the curious position of being able to dictate to his former enemy the terms of the town's restoration.
还有一件事。他们最感兴趣购买的土地与斯科特·布拉德利市长的财产合并在一起。除非布拉德利也同意出售，否则他们不会买任何土地。佩罗非常渴望这笔钱。这使布拉德利处于一个奇特的境地，能够向他以前的敌人下达镇子恢复的条件。
He did. In December of 1998, 314 acres of ranch land was sold to the Fidelity Corporation. And in exchange, Perot abandoned all legal action against the town of Westlake. The town was restored. After two years of struggle, Westlake was saved by the very thing its citizens were trying to avoid in the first place-- development. This did not diminish in any way the sweetness of the Supreme Court ruling which reinstated Scott Bradley as mayor, which was delivered to Scott by his state representative, Vicki Truitt, on April 9, 1999.
他做了。1998年12月，314英亩的牧场土地被卖给了Fidelity公司。作为交换，佩罗放弃了所有针对韦斯特莱克镇的法律行动。镇子恢复了。经过两年的斗争，韦斯特莱克被其公民最初试图避免的事情所拯救——开发。这丝毫没有减少最高法院恢复斯科特·布拉德利市长职务裁决的甜美，该裁决由他的州代表维基·特鲁特于1999年4月9日转达给斯科特。
They had declared that I was, and still am, the mayor of the town of Westlake. And it was just total screaming. Vicki was screaming and crying. We were screaming and crying. And then the news just spread like wildfire. The news must've been around the town in half an hour.
他们宣布我曾是，现在仍然是韦斯特莱克镇的市长。那简直是全场尖叫。维基在尖叫和哭泣。我们在尖叫和哭泣。然后新闻像野火一样蔓延开来。半小时内新闻一定传遍了全镇。
I think, as Americans, that a lot of people out there that have assumed that money and power will carry the day, that our experience teaches us that most of the times, money and power does win. And therefore, there's more of a resignation to that fact and a willingness to succumb because we know, or we think, that's going to be the ultimate result anyway. And I think it's almost shocking to us when we find out that, if people will stand up, and if you will fight for what I keep calling the right thing, that ultimately it can win out even over money and power.
我认为，作为美国人，很多人都认为金钱和权力会胜出，我们的经验教训告诉我们，大多数时候，金钱和权力确实赢了。因此，人们对此事实更加顺从，也更愿意屈服，因为我们知道，或者我们认为，那最终会是结果。我认为当我们发现，如果人们站起来，如果你为你坚持称之为“正确的事情”而战，最终它甚至可以战胜金钱和权力时，我们几乎感到震惊。
The people of Westlake had always assumed that the aldermen had sold the town out to Perot for money. But in the end, there's no evidence to support this theory. Only one of the aldermen, Jerry Moore, sold his property to Perot directly, for a price reasonably within market range. And no other evidence of quid pro quo has surfaced. In the meantime, almost all of the aldermen have moved away from Westlake. They say it's just too hard after all that's happened, and the town has changed. Al Oien is the only one who continues to own property in town, but says he mostly keeps to himself.
韦斯特莱克的人们一直认为议员们为了钱把镇子卖给了佩罗。但最终，没有任何证据支持这一理论。只有一名议员杰里·摩尔直接以市场范围内合理的价格将他的财产卖给了佩罗。没有出现任何其他利益交换的证据。与此同时，几乎所有的议员都已经搬离了韦斯特莱克。他们说在发生了这一切之后太难了，而且镇子已经变了。阿尔·奥伊恩是唯一一个继续在镇上拥有财产的人，但他说他大多独自一人。
After two years, the people of Westlake had their town back. And though many seemed to believe with Scott Bradley that the moral of this story is very clear, that right will in the end trump might, that money doesn't always win, a funny thing happened on the way to victory. The people of Westlake seemed to lose sight of their original goal of keeping the town rural.
两年后，韦斯特莱克的人民拿回了他们的镇子。虽然许多人似乎和斯科特·布拉德利一样相信这个故事的寓意非常明确，即正义终将战胜强权，金钱并不总是赢家，但在通往胜利的路上发生了一件有趣的事情。韦斯特莱克的人们似乎忽略了他们保持镇子农村状态的最初目标。
Talk to Don or Ruby or David or Scott today, and they will speak enthusiastically about the new Fidelity campus. They even seem reconciled to the idea of more building. People now accept that there is development, that there will be more development. And in this sense, Perot may have lost the battle, but has managed to lay the groundwork to win the war.
今天与唐、露比、戴维或斯科特交谈，他们会热情地谈论新的Fidelity园区。他们甚至似乎对更多建设的想法达成了和解。人们现在接受了这里有开发，将来会有更多开发。从这个意义上讲，佩罗可能输掉了战斗，但已经为赢下战争奠定了基础。
Before I left Westlake, I went to visit Perot's company, the Hillwood Corporation. They wouldn't speak about the past, but they were happy to talk about the future. David Pelletier, a spokesman for the company, brought out a big, color-coded map and showed me their plans.
在我离开韦斯特莱克之前，我去拜访了佩罗的公司Hillwood公司。他们不愿谈论过去，但他们很高兴谈论未来。公司发言人戴维·佩勒蒂尔拿出了一张大型彩色编码地图，向我展示了他们的计划。
We've already sold this property to Texas Health Systems for a hospital campus. That's already been approved by the town. This right here, we were working with General Growth Properties, one of the largest mall developers and mall management companies in the country, to come in. And it's going to be a high-level, upscale shopping resort.
我们已经把这处房产卖给了德克萨斯医疗系统作为医院园区。这已经得到了镇上的批准。这儿，我们正在与全国最大的购物中心开发商和购物中心管理公司之一General Growth Properties合作，让他们进来。这将是一个高水平、高档的购物度假胜地。
He pointed out the industrial office complex, the luxury hotel, multi-family housing projects, and finally, the Texas town that Hillwood had first proposed back in 1996. They're still planning to build it. Construction will soon be underway.
他指出了工业办公园区、豪华酒店、多户住房项目，最后是Hillwood早在1996年首次提议的德克萨斯小镇。他们仍然计划建造它。建设很快就会开始。
Alix Spiegel. She produced her story with funding from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
阿利克斯·斯皮格尔。她制作了这个故事，并得到了公共广播公司Corporation for Public Broadcasting的资助。
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, and Blue Chevigny, contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, Nancy Updie, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Mary Wiltenburg.
好吧，我们今天的节目是由朱莉·斯奈德和我自己，以及亚历克斯·布隆伯格、苏珊·伯顿、蓝色·切维尼制作的，贡献编辑包括保罗·塔夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、南希·阿普迪和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自托德·巴赫曼和玛丽·威尔滕堡。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
To buy a cassette of this program call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. You know, you can listen to our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site. Thanks to Joanne, Dale, and Rob, of The Cola Mail System, for hosting our weekly email Listserv news update. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
要购买本节目的录音带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ，电话312-832-3380。你知道，你可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org上免费在线收听我们的节目。感谢运营该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。感谢Cola邮件系统的乔安、戴尔和罗伯主持我们的每周电子邮件列表服务器新闻更新。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who declares after every episode of our program,
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他在我们节目的每一集结束后都会宣布，
I can't believe what this man has done. I'm sitting there, thinking, "I must be in Russia."
我不敢相信这个人做了什么。我坐在那儿想，“我一定是在俄罗斯。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。